it's not easy being a kid in Hawkins
Indiana well with all the attacks from
supernatural creatures but did you know
that it's also not easy being an actor
on Stranger Things From specific
language on what to say in interviews to
haircut fans let's take a look at some
of the strict rules that the cast on
this monster of a show have had to abide
by in an era of spoilers and leaks
Studios try to keep their content Under
Wraps until they decide to release it
and Netflix is no exception the cast of
stranger things are given explicit
orders to keep details about the plot
and the show in general a secret but
it's not just a simple statement they
agree to they're each given Specific
Instructions on what they are allowed to
say in interviews and maybe more
importantly what they're not allowed to
say this was revealed by actress
Francesca real who said each of them got
a sheet emailed to them that outlined
the no-nos and yes yeses of stranger
things info then there's the fact that
when Netflix sends out publicity
screeners to the Press they password
protect the files that way if anything
gets leaked they'll know who leaked it
based on their personal password but
apparently that wasn't enough for
Netflix because when it came to their
own cast They reportedly didn't even
give them passwords yup the cast had to
wait just like the rest of us to see
their beautiful faces on Netflix when
the show got released each season
speaking of keeping things under wraps
there's reportedly a strict no cell
phones rule that the cast has to abide
by for starters it reduces the chances
of someone forgetting to put theirs away
AKA so there aren't any shots that
include an iPhone popping up in a show
set 40 years ago it's also so the actors
can feel even more like they're in the
1980s obviously their characters didn't
have cell phones so not having them on
set potentially makes them feel more
connected to the role plus it helps them
stay present on set and More in touch
with their co-workers because apparently
human interaction is easier without
simultaneously Doom scrolling on social
media who knew but the no cell phone
rule is mostly there because Netflix
doesn't want photos or videos
accidentally leaked out so the actors
are asked not only to keep their cell
phones offset but also not to take
photos and vids of behind the scenes
Stuff Plus they're given strict
guidelines about what to post or not
post on social media so since they can't
be on their phones they can focus on
more important things like their hair or
actually scratch that because they're
basically restricted from messing around
with that too the haircuts in stranger
things are obviously all 80s specific so
nobody is allowed to do anything drastic
to their hair without running it by
production first but the biggest
restriction is on Joe Kiri of course for
anyone who has actually seen the show
that's probably not a surprise because
Joe was blessed with the dreamiest of
Dreamboat heads of hair and one that
looks like it was specifically designed
to be in stranger things Joe's styled
hair is so important to the show he's
not allowed to get a haircut without
explicit permission from the powers that
be but perhaps a small price to pay for
being gifted those luscious locks Joe
and the other boys is also have to pay a
small price when it comes to their
physique because the show centers around
a group of kids who are pretty slender
that has essentially become as much of
an artistic element as any of the
costumes or sets so The Duffer brothers
who created the show are Keen to keep
that aesthetic going that means the boys
on the show aren't allowed to gain a lot
of muscle mass which can be a bit tricky
for kids who are going through their
teen years you know what with puberty
and all but they're asked to keep skinny
to the best of their abilities the only
exception to this was daker Montgomery
who played Billy Hargrove daker was told
early on that his character wasn't a
part of the no muscles crew and that he
was free to get his checked as he wanted
but it's not just the male cast members
who have these kinds of rules the girls
and everyone else for that matter are
not allowed to show up to set wearing
makeup this rule didn't always exist but
one day while filming season one Millie
Bobby Brown showed up in makeup that had
some glitter in it and as we all know
about Glitter that stuff is hard to get
off completely apparent apparently just
getting her back to normal took an extra
45 minutes that delayed the entire day
of shooting which as you can probably
guess cost the studio money and that's a
No-No people so from then on the cast
has had to show up fresh-faced it's also
because the makeup in the 1980s was a
lot different than it is today and since
the makeup Pros working on the show have
that nailed the producers would rather
they do it than rely on the actresses to
do it speaking of relying on the acting
cast they aren't explicitly asked not to
take other roles so that's good but at
the same time they aren't totally
allowed to do whatever they want before
signing on to do any other acting
projects they have to check in with the
stranger things scheduling Department
first and if there's a conflict they
have to say a polite no to the other
project so that can be somewhat limiting
for a show that doesn't exactly look
like it's shot in three weeks right Finn
wolfhard actually had a situation arise
where it was looking like he'd have to
choose between taking his role in the
movie it and continuing on stranger
things and apparently fan was about to
say bye to stranger things nobody wants
that finny boy fortunately it all worked
out because stranger things ended up
going on a shooting Hiatus for a year so
he never had to make that call thanks
okay so now that I know the lengths
everyone is going to just to give us
this amazing series it makes me
appreciate stranger things even more I
just just wish I had Joe kiri's hair I
promise I'd never cut it without
permission have any thoughts about the
cast rules on Stranger Things pop them
in the comments